у 2012 уродських на кордоні mesh польші
то Калінінградської області за дроти ви
малий при кордоні рук нехай на каналі
пк а у паспорті давалося мову як
росіянам так і полякам без нудних розуму
джей пройти над і кордон з червня базі
візовий прикордонний рук казав і
нелегко доладного то я вам скажу просто
to know трюми звезу
акція була треба турніки з купити з
чимось користь інших а ти за бронево ти
в готель а бонусу проханням як усі
коротше друзі живуть пошукайте в євросоюзі
то так ринок союзу просто на 3 мотай у
нас у євросоюзі
де мало при кордонному руку покликала
економіку містечку бартошице на не жукам
нитки роберта петровського товару апекс
круті вся в дівочі на мою думку
малий при кордонний рук
новий то його в грають місяці лежить
або росіян та малий бізнес седан
і давно до місцевих супермаркетів
проїзд автобус це привозу ви клієнті
з калінінграду сьогодні що ляша кирико
росіян вирішила і краще вікнами на дачі
товари дійшли недавно російський
купівлі у хочеш скупого ласвіль і
фрукти і мене з собою вас ви на і але у
вакуумних упаковках
закрити і курей думи з Калінінградом
блазень але в дар його помістив їх фермерам
скажіть хенрік лозинський
кретова росія забрані lan порт уват
європейським я сам убити по бо на за
сильний санкції нас і до конфлікту з
україною через менше не з досвіду нас
вийнявши підлоги стіни фермер бум чоловіка з
кріт і д повалій особливо з 5 тисяч до
700 тварин через оборону імпорту заходу
у Росії дорослого рибницького м'ясо особливо
його у Калінінградській області в team
стане спинки польських підприємливий
заправляючись 2014 року експорт польських
товариш зр snap-on відвести сотки
виправи витрату клієнту в виросли нам
адреса вигляд і русі вигода для гігантська
то при благо ринку алла цифри switch
від про інший російський ринок можна
застосовувати з іспанським купе вільно з
промисловістю росіян менота виграв
ще ера диско сови немалого при корді
багато руку польша а знаючи ні євросоюз ще
більше дистанцію
стегна see